الشركه البولنديه المصنعه لهذه العربه
ستقوم بتزويد وزاره الدفاع بالف عربه
لمهام الهجوم و400 عربه اخرى لمهام
الاسناد الميدانيه هذه العربه صممت لتكون
عربه برمائيه تصل سرعتها على البر حتى
سبعين كيلو مترا في الساعه في حين تصل
سرعتها في المياه الى ثمانيه كيلو مترات
في الساعه الواحده
المدرع بورسك سيتم تجهيزها ببرج مسلح
ومزود بمدفع رشاش ثقيل من عيار 30 ملي متر
وكذلك مدفع رشاش اخر متوسط من عيار
7.62 مليمتر سيتم تزويد هذه العربه ايضا
بصاروخين موجهين من طراز سبايك المضاد
للضروع
ايضا سيتم تزويدها بمنظومه توجيه نيران
الكترونيه هذه المنظومه ستمكنها من اصابه
الاهداف بدقه كبيره كما انها ستكون ايضا
مزوده بمنظومه رؤيا حراريه ليليه اضافه
الى منظومه دفاع نشط هذه المنظومه ستمكنها
من التعامل مع الصواريخ الموجهه بالليزر